Oh teaching jobs Eston elves Pete
Davidson says he won't be doing any more
college comedy appearances cuz
everyone's just too offended in a recent
interview he says I refuse to do a
college after this year because it's
like you're just setting yourself up for
trouble he's not the first to write off
the home of dwindling free speech both
Seinfeld and Chris Rock have also
ditched academia as the toxic mold of
humor lessness spreads so why is it
getting so bad two words identity
politics
I can't even list the offended without
triggering outrage once the modern left
made identity the center of one's being
they created endless varieties of
grievance which then creates the same
number of potential offenses there are
now more identities than people as thick
skins have been replaced with open
wounds no more a country based on rugged
individuals among the young it's now
replaced by cowardly mobs so what can
today's comics say to those who demand
to be shielded from uncomfortable truths
and offensive jokes it'd be great if
they said something but rather than
share the risk that they bail the front
lines of speech seem in retreat leaving
all but a few to fight on it's up to us
to reward the fighters and ignore those
who don't if not then the joke will be
on all of us and no one will be laughing
because we'll all be suing so Emily I
hope you were awake for that should the
opposite be pursued if comedians go to
the places and dare to be canceled like
we dare to be canceled on this show
every day but it's impossible because
we're too good yeah I think I think that
would be the aim but the reality is that
people are getting cancelled people are
getting denied people are locking arms
at uc-berkeley that other students can't
penetrate to attend to talk so I I wish
that Pete Davidson and people like him
could be brave enough to say like yeah
I'm gonna do it anyway but the reality I
mean why so why should he do it so he
can cancel or sue that he can get
cancelled so that people won't even be
able to attend I went to school in San
Francisco I've talked about this before
I was president of the Federalist
Society there and my job was to provide
the other side for every debate and it
was San Francisco of course it was
totally liberal and I never ever got
anything like that it was always welcome
to have two sides and a
course the unpopular side would always
get you know dumped on after and
questions and whatever but it was never
the extent that it was and when I see UC
Berkeley where I grew up it just makes
me sad that that level of ignorance
frankly is what is preventing that
actual discourse we don't want you sad
Emily
hey one this criticism is transcending
politics you see Bill Maher progressive
condemning the same kind of cancel
culture and and kind of the comedy cops
it's not just consensus that
conservatives probably saw it coming
before the lefted because the
Conservatives got hit earlier with it by
going to campuses but now everybody
agrees Bill Maher got canceled by people
who were conservative who said he was
not patriotic right but also by the left
when he used the n-word
well that's afterwards yeah I agree but
you know what strikes me is that not
only is Bill Maher but you know people
like Dave Chappelle spoken out about
this but the difference is Maher &
Chapelle have gone to in one case HBO
the other case Netflix and they do fine
yes because it's an older broader
audience but I think young people are
far more sensitive to the idea that you
are speaking in a way that is offensive
and so sad but I agree because I think
you know what I see is that even big
corporations big corporations will not
say you know what you're too political
or you're too this you're too that they
don't want to take the risk yeah ending
some interest group inside that is true
especially the last couple of years
Jesse this idea of sensitivity is like
it's harmful to people right I mean
you've got a thick skin or you get
nowhere
well I blame liberals they're the ones
that created canceled culture they
created political correctness and now
they're getting deprived of funny jokes
on college and that liberal comedians
can't get the gigs done it's like the
robots that you warned us about yes you
create these robots all of a sudden they
come around and then they shoot you this
is what's happening they created the
analogy political correctness and that
it's devouring the people that created
at permission to making it now I would
like it you just did Syria's got a lot
of oil but Exxon doesn't want to go in
there because it's too dangerous
that's what college campus is like now
it's too dangerous to go in
it's like the Syria of this country it's
not worth that there's too much to lose
but do you remember in the 80s just a
few years ago college campus is the
craziest edgiest most hilarious places
there ever was that's where people
wanted to go there were spring break you
know that was crazy now it's just the
opposite
Dana you had crazy times in college you
were a Hellraiser I don't think a
comedian ever came there but it was
Pablo Colorado a great place but not a
rodeo clown comedy it was a positive
comment there's a place in New York
called the Comedy Cellar that I know
you've been a few times there's an
actual silver fine but and then there's
a comedian there named Jessica Kirsten I
believe that's it and I started
listening to her podcast it's very very
funny and she just rips Republicans up
one side and down the other and I laugh
it's like very funny but she interviews
other comedians and all of them in every
episode they talked about how they
basically are censoring themselves on
stage in order to prevent this
cancelling yeah remember when I went to
see I've just forgot his name but you
know I'm talking about great the guy who
rants guy who ran oh the dude yes the
guy from do the right thing the hall
obnoxious guy yes what's it you can do
anyway so he he for the first time used
we in Santa Fe New York this is a super
successful comic and I'll remember the
name after this segment closet and he
said on stage he didn't say anything
political this is a guy who who is super
famous for his anti Trump rants and he
said on stage I was warned by my by my
comedian friends not to get political
and he didn't and everyone was kind of
like then why did we come yeah that's
funny part we can laugh at that yeah
sure make Michael Michael yeah its first
name is Michael